about a year ago Andy George from the
channel how to make everything released
a video called how to make a $1500
sandwich in only six months I mean a
chicken sandwich completely from scratch
which cost $1500 six months of my life
the video was hugely successful they got
millions of views then a few weeks ago
Andy came to me with a question
obviously I didn't use the most
efficient method in making my sandwich
but why is there such a huge gap in
price between the sandwich I made for
$1,500 when you can just buy at a store
much less my nearest grocery store sells
pre-made chicken sandwiches for two
pounds about two and a half US dollars
that's 600 times cheaper than Andy's
sandwich the economic principle that
really makes the modern commercial world
go round
his economies of scale you might
remember from history class that an
important step in the development of
humanity was the beginning of
specialization of Labor that was the
point when advancements in technology
were far enough along that the amount of
food one person could produce was higher
than the amount one person needed to
survive since there was a surplus some
people could go and do other things like
science research writing and even
production this also helps spur the
development of the first real cities
since everyone didn't have to live on
farms specialization of Labor was in a
way the very beginning of the use of
economies of scale because instead of
everyone growing and making everything
they needed different people did with
dated best and exchanged Goods to get
what they needed
fast forward almost ten thousand years
and the world is almost entirely
specialized individuals almost never
make things for themselves except for
Andy George challenged myself to see if
I could as an individual make something
as basic as a sandwich entirely by
myself I grew all my own vegetables
harvested and ground my own wheat to
make bread kill them butchered my own
chicken even flew all the way from
Minneapolis to LA collect ocean water to
boil down for salt the salt is what were
gonna focus on the reason is because
Andy salt production process was almost
identical to that of a larger firm he
had to gather raw materials process it
into a product then transport it to a
final market
those three steps have been optimized in
our modern world to yield insane cost
reductions in order to make myself I
spent two hundred and ninety eight
dollars eighty eight cents on a plane
ticket fifty seven dollars to rent a
boat in 641 for a five-gallon jug all
just to gather the few ounces of salt I
needed he only needed a small amount but
for the same price he could have
gathered more than a pounds worth for
his six ounces of salt and he paid three
hundred and sixty two dollars and forty
cents that's fifty two dollars per ounce
more than triple the cost of silver each
gallon of seawater yields about 4.5
ounces of salt when evaporated so his
five gallon jug could have carried
enough water to make twenty two point
five ounces of salt or one point four
pounds at that production rate the cost
per ounce is sixteen dollars but we can
make it even cheaper we just need more
five gallon jugs if we buy say nine more
five gallon jugs at 6.41 cents each our
total costs would be four hundred and
nineteen dollars and ninety eight cents
but we can make fourteen pounds of salt
that brings the cost down to one dollar
and eighty-seven cents per ounce but we
can keep scaling this up to an extent
Andy's method of transport was flying
and at that base rate his total cargo
capacity was only the capacity of his
carry-on bag the largest carry-on bags
have a capacity of forty five liters or
eleven point eight gallons one gallon of
salt weighs 18 point one pounds so
assuming nobody ever checks the bag
Andy could have carried two hundred and
thirteen point six pounds of salt to
produce that much Andy would have needed
a hundred and fifty three 5-gallon jugs
and the boat he was on could have only
carried about ten so he would have
needed to rent fifteen more so if we add
together the plane ticket the 153 gallon
jugs and the sixteen boat rentals we get
a total price of two thousand one
hundred and ninety one dollars and fifty
eight cents a lot more but it's worth it
because at this production rate the salt
only costs sixty four cents per ounce
but we can keep scaling the average rate
to hire a los angeles-based 40-foot semi
truck
two dollars per mile to drive the 1912
miles from Los Angeles California to
Minneapolis Minnesota it would therefore
cost three thousand eight hundred and
twenty-four dollars the usable capacity
for these trucks is two thousand three
hundred and ninety five cubic feet or
seventeen thousand nine hundred and
sixteen liquid gallons for three hundred
and twenty-five thousand pounds worth of
salt sounds great but the US only allows
a total gross weight of 80 thousand
pounds on the road and that has to
include the weight of the truck itself
so the actual transport capacity is only
about 40,000 pounds salt is just so
dense that we can't load a truck to its
full volume capacity so we'll just
produce 40,000 pounds of salt and for
that we need two thousand eight hundred
and fifty seven boat rentals and 28
thousand five hundred and seventy one
5-gallon jugs for the sake of
explanation we'll pretend that we can't
reuse the five gallon jugs those boat
rentals would total up to one hundred
and sixty two thousand eight hundred and
forty nine dollars and the jugs would
add up to a hundred and eighty three
thousand one hundred and forty-one
dollars so including the transport cost
by truck producing forty thousand pounds
of salt would cost three hundred and
forty nine thousand eight hundred and
fourteen dollars that's now a cost of
fifty four cents per ounce as you can
see as you get into higher and higher
levels of production the advantage of
producing more grows smaller it was 25
times cheaper to produce two hundred and
fourteen pounds of salt than to produce
one point four pounds of salt on a
hundred and fifty two times increase in
production but increasing the production
from two hundred and fourteen pounds to
forty thousand pounds a three hundred
and fourteen times increase only
decreases the price by 1.1 nine times
let's shake up the production process
instead of boiling the seawater down to
salt in Los Angeles and transporting it
to Minneapolis let's say the Andy
transported the seawater to Minneapolis
then boil it down what would it cost
then well seawater weighs about eight
point six pounds per gallon and once
again we can only carry about forty
thousand pounds or 4651 gallons this
will cost three thousand eight
and $24 for the truck five thousand nine
hundred and sixty eight dollars for nine
hundred and thirty one 5-gallon jugs
five thousand three hundred and fifty
eight dollars for ninety four boat
rentals and in the end will only yield
one thousand three hundred and eight
pounds of salt to make these one
thousand three hundred and eight pounds
we spent sixty cents per ounce
a difference of six cents per gallon may
not seem like a big deal but once you
get to the scale of producing say one
hundred thousand pounds of salt those
six cents add up to ninety six thousand
dollars more than the price of a Tesla
Model S this demonstrates a very
important principle in manufacturing
there are essentially two types of
products weight losing and weight
gaining salt is one of the greatest
examples of a weight losing product you
put in a lot of raw materials in this
case sea water to make a little product
obviously it doesn't make sense to ship
the raw sea water cross-country when you
can just boil it down in Los Angeles
this is why processing plants for almost
all weight losing products will be
located near the source the other type
of product is weight gaining you take a
small amount of raw material and make it
into something much heavier or larger a
great example of this is coca-cola they
have more than 900 bottling plants
worldwide just so they can lower cost
if transport was not a factor at all
they could achieve lower costs by having
one single mega factory but once their
soda is me they still have to get it to
the end consumer the cost of transport
is closely linked to weight so since
they just take a small amount of flavors
and ingredients and add it to water
something available almost anywhere it
makes sense to produce their product
near the end consumer overall we
achieved a 92 fold reduction in cost of
salt by using the principles of mass
production every single ingredient
Andy George used to make his $1,500
sandwich could have benefited from the
principles of mass production we also
could have gone even further we could
have rented a bigger boat used bigger
containers there were plenty of ways we
could have driven down prices even more
but these type of cost reductions make
the difference in our mod
in World between a $1,500 and a $5
chicken sandwich I hope you enjoyed this
Wendover productions video I first need
to give a huge thanks to my sponsor Liu
Mara as I'm sure you know from my old
Wai College is so expensive video
college is expensive and Liu merit helps
you do college for less whether you're
already in college or want to be Liu
Merit Scholar helps you get the same
degree from the same College for
thousands of dollars less Liu Mayer
allows you to take up to three years of
college from anywhere in the world
on your own schedule for four thousand
dollars a year or less once you're ready
to enroll in a traditional college there
in-house degree specialists will make
sure that all your earned credits
transfer if this sounds interesting to
you head over to go to merit comm slash
went over to see how much you could save
with Liu Merit Scholar they'll send you
an email and then you'll receive a
one-on-one consultation to see if Liu
merit is right for you please be sure to
also check out Andy George's channel how
to make everything for all sorts of
great videos on making things from
scratch he just released a great video
exploring where the money you pay for
coffee actually goes somewhat similar to
my wife lying is so expensive video so
you'll see an appearance from yours
truly I also recently started a patreon
which you can go to by clicking here
there are a bunch of great rewards like
early access to videos stickers t-shirts
and best of all every dollar contributed
over there goes right back into the
channel
aside from that please follow me on
Twitter at Wendover Pro watch my last
video on urban geography check out my
fan moderated subreddit at wwe.com slash
are slash win over productions and most
of all subscribe to this channel thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
two weeks for another Wendover
productions video